[Musique]
pour
la multiplication des acteurs est pas un
problème il faut qu'on arrête de
regarder la question sous l'angle de la
fragmentation des collectivités ou des
acteurs si déjà chacun fait le maximum
dans son couloir de nage dans son
domaine de compétence
déjà le bond sera fait combien de
collage is impressive 17 collèges 77
collège déjà le jour tous les collèges
de la réunion seront en autoconsommation
à la base d'énergie photovoltaïque avec
une solution de stockage le bon on
avancera fait espaces naturels sensibles
c'est une compétence reconnue de par la
loi pour le conseil départemental à ces
submersibles un vrai sens du sort et ce
comme j'ai passé du temps avec le
président didier robert ce matin au
conseil régional comme j'aime passer du
temps avec nos président melchior chacun
à sa place le combat avec gigantesque
donc le mobilisation des énergies sans
mauvais jeu de mots de chacun est
importante
[Musique]
chacun doit faire un peu mais il faut
donner de la cohérence dans les actions
faites par les uns et par les autres
vous avez bien sûr l'état
vous avez la région les
intercommunalités les opérateurs
économiques
et puis bien sûr le département mais il
faut que tout ce monde là travaillent
ensemble mieux travailler ensemble pour
réussir un beau projet de développement
durable pour notre île c'est cela notre
ambition
[Musique]